what's going on everybody welcome to
this second beautifulsoup tutorial in
our little beautifulsoup mini-series
in this tutorial we're going to be doing
is slightly more I suppose getting
something really specific from my page
where you can sort of think of it like
navigation but it's not totally like
navigation like some other libraries
have so anyway let's get into it so I'm
going to go ahead and just delete
everything up to the soup so so first
let's say let's say our objective was to
get all the URLs but really we just
wanted like a specific set of URLs so
you could say right for URL in soup dot
find underscore all a and then you print
them out and stuff okay so we could do
that route
but instead what if we like maybe we
rather than getting like the body URLs
maybe this is something we want to
actually parse like the just that
website we want to start navigating
around that website so rather than
taking the URLs that are in the body
text of that website maybe we want to do
the nav bar okay so instead we could say
something like this right remember we
could do soup dot P and that gives us
like a paragraph tag we can do soup nav
and that will be basically the first nav
that it comes across so nav can equal
soup not now so now let's just to see
what we've got let's print the nav and
sure enough it's basically all of the
nav here cool so we'll close that and
then now what we're going to do is we'll
we want to find the URLs so actually the
process to do that I shouldn't have
deleted that other thing but anyway for
a URL in nav find underscore all we will
find all the a tags and then we can say
print URL dot get and we want to get a
Chara so this should give us all the
links that it finds in the nav bar so
here are all the links now just for the
record it's finding basically double the
links because let me go to the website
we basically have two nav bars on this
website right this is one of the nav
bars
so it's like the the mobile version or
small screen version right that's on the
side here but if you're not how do I
know how to make this go there we go now
I control my own website anyway if we
make it bigger
now the nav bars on top but that other
nav bars like there the codes there for
it so that's why it's actually being
found
so anyways just close that so now we
have all the links from the the nav bar
now again also in many cases you could
do something like this you could say
body equals soup body but in our case
that's for paragraph and souped-up find
oops actually body or let's say for
paragraph in yet body dot find all P we
can print paragraph text but we're going
to find that this has actually that
worked out better than I thought I was
going to work out half isn't expecting
that so actually that ended up working
out but we have two to two body tags and
I wasn't expecting that it was actually
going to find that so on a lot of
websites they are like their content
will be within a bot actually you know
what I think I removed the body tag now
that I'm thinking about it
yeah remove the second body tag before I
went into here that's that's what happen
anyway so so that's one option that you
have so we were able to have to just get
just the text from the body and in most
scraping cases like if you're just
scraping a website and that's you're
just looking for some basic text data
this should be more than enough to just
get that body data and so like if you're
scraping for content that's all you
really need to do the other thing you
could do is like for example the reason
why I got rid of the body tag is I added
this div and then class equals body well
and sometimes you'll see something like
this because there might be multiple
body tags or there might be a really
specific kind of div section that you're
hoping to parse and so let's show kind
of an example there so what what you
might think to
do is like okay well we could say for
div in soup dot find all div we could
try to print the div text and then I'm
going to see soup yeah so we'll just do
that and then we'll print that right
you're getting all of the div tag text
so that's kind of a pain so one thing
that beautiful soup allows us to do is
actually have a div but we can also
specify a class you just class
underscore since classes a class so
class underscore we can say body there
and then you could say for div I'm going
to run that really quick right so that's
good enough that gives us exactly what
we were kind of hoping for so in this
case remember this one is for a
paragraph embodied find all paragraphs
so that other one's not going to find
the stuff that's not within paragraph
tags where is this this is finding
basically all of the text that's between
div tags all right so that's like a
little bit more about navigation just
remember that you can you can basically
specify a new beautifulsoup object right
so this is a the whole beautiful soup
then we're saying here just that first
navbar and then we're able to just work
between those navbar tags so again it's
problem maybe if you're not too familiar
with working with HTML right that's
basically when we did a nav equals soup
nav we're basically dealing with
basically here where are you nav two
here right just that chunk so we've
sliced out that chunk of information
okay so that's going to conclude the
second beautiful soup tutorial we've got
one more tutorial I'm going to be
talking about tables since that's
probably one of the basically the three
most common things I found myself
needing to scrape is first the con
then URLs then tables so we're going to
talk about tables in the next tutorial
so stay tuned for that if you have
questions comments concerns whatever on
this tutorial feel free to leave them
below
remember text-based tutorials on Python
programming net as well as the sample
code that we wrote and I'll see you in
the next tutorial